you
the in store data a professing tiara no
babe please target em a Shimon it is a
great honor to introduce the Nobel
laureate in chemistry professor Michael
Levitz
ESMA gesture is cooling over Herto Nez
excellency Minda mohara yard Borya
epicenter for the sister adhere food for
under can limit our coordinate important
firm have to abetted some further need
heat no English
your Majesties you're all Highnesses
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen I
start in Swedish to prove that I can
still learn something 45 years after
doing the work that brought me here I
love the Swedish people for the
detective novels for the Rockapella go
for their sense of humor for the
sparkling vodka and especially for their
wonderful hospitality I have been to
Sweden over a dozen times
I came to malmö as a student in 1964 to
drink on the ferry from Copenhagen and
it returns the scientists to lund
göteborg
link shop in Stockholm Uppsala and umeå
computers are now so much part of our
lives that it's hard to imagine the dark
ages of computing let us think in terms
of a motor car a Volvo costing say four
thousand dollars in 1967 or $30,000 in
today's money if cars had improved like
computers did then the new model would
cost 20 kronor we're going million miles
an hour were carried 50 thousand people
in comfort and parking a shoebox
this this power for change has pushed
all signs ahead it propelled the field
that we pioneered to the point where it
was recognized by the 2013 chemistry
committee I thank them not for the
obvious reason that they selected me and
my fellow laureates Martin Coppola
scenario Varsha
no it is because they were brave and
daring enough to recognize a new field
computational structural biology will be
increasingly important in improving
human health which we can all say thank
you